COLLEAGUES ARE IN ROUTE BUT I
HAVE A FEW ARE TECHNICAL
OPENING COMMENTS THAT THEY HAVE
HEARD OF MULTIPLE TIMES ALREADY
SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND MAKE THOSE
COMMENTS. SO GOOD AFTERNOON I
GET NO I GUESS IT'S STILL
MORNING GOOD MORNING. I MAKE A
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
AGAIN EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE. OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR CONTINUED PATIENCE. ARE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR
THOSE TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST
TIME. I'M GOING TO COVER SOME
OF THE TECHNICAL SIDES- SIX THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
THE DAY- IN RESPONSE TO KOBE
NINETEEN- MERCHANTS SEEING TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING SO IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS. THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS IS SENT HEARING
AND WE ATE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BOB
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. AND ARE
VALUABLE EMPLOYEES. I HOLD THE
COMMITTEE BRING HERE CAPITAL TO
ALLOW OUR PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
IN MID AND NOW OF MEMBERS OF
THE TO HEAR A ROOMS TO THE X.
THAT SO DID REQUIRED
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE'LL
ALSO OF COURSE BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY ABBOTT WHO
ARE NOT HERE PHYSICALLY. ARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT'LL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IT'S
GOING TO BE PUT UP RIGHT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN NINE
SEVEN FIVE ZERO AGAIN THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN NINE SEVEN FIVE ZERO
AGAIN IT IS ON OUR WEBSITE AND
WILL REPEAT IT AGAIN- AS WE
MOVE TO EACH APPOINTMENT. WE
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WHEN WE GET TO THE
TELECONFERENCE PARK YOU WILL
OPEN THE YOUR LINE WILL BE
OPENED AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU WILL HAVE TO MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. AND
IT'S SO THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE MAY GIVE
THAT REMINDER AGAIN BECAUSE
WE'RE ALL GETTING USED TO THIS
PROCESS. I. RITUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE- TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO AGAIN PLEASE BE
PATIENT AND ARE WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE CAN BE HER.
AND ALSO WELL DO ONE NOTE ON
BEHALF OF OUR STENOGRAPHER I
ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESSES A LIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY- SO THAT SHE
IS ABLE TO- TO TAKE DOWN YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR- INFORMATION.
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WE MUST ESTABLISH A QUORUM. A
REMINDER TO OUR COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON FOR ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE AND WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL OUR ROLE. HERE
BATES HERE MINING YEAR MINING
HERE ROB ROB HERE WILK
RESIDENTS WILL PRESENT ATKINS
YOUR ATKINS HERE. THANK YOU. I
WILL BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT AND THAT
WOULD BE MS LORD IS COST FOR A
WERE MERECE TO SECRETARY OF
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT- AS AN INTRODUCTION WE
HAVE THE CABINET SECRETARY ON A
MODIFIED TOES ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HERE SO I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO YOU FOR THAT
INTRODUCTION. WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM RETURN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO JOIN YOU ON FOR
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING IT IS A
PRIVILEGE TO GET TO WORK WITH
SECRETARY CUSTOMER MEETING AND
WAS SECRETARY REPORTS AND EVERY
DAY. THEY HAVE THE- THEY ASSUME
THESE ROLES IN A PARTICULARLY
TRYING TIME THEY CAME TO US IN
A SEALED THEIR LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS ARE. TWO DAYS FOR THE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY
ASSOCIATED WITH OVER NINETEEN.
AND I LIKE IT VERY THEIR
LEADERSHIP OF THE WAY IN WHICH
THEY WORK TO BUILD COMMUNITY
THE WAY IN WHICH THEY'VE WORKED
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS THEIR
DIRECTORS. AND TO LEAD THE
TEAM. AN UNPRECEDENTED TIMES.
BE AT WORK ALL AROUND PROJECT
ROOM KEY BE AT WORK ON ENSURING
THAT WE ARE RESTRUCTURING OUR
PROGRAM IS ON THE WAY WHEN WE
DO WORK TO EXCEL. NECESSARY
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. AND THE-
OUR STATE IS EMPLOY AT ON HOW
TO WE MAKE SURE THE WE HAVE WE
THAT REPRESENT A OUR THAT WE
GET PROGRAMS LIKE COMFORT
TRACING GOING THAT WE GET THAT-
TO THE WORK AT HOME POLICIES
TAKING ON BARGAINING
RESPONSIBILITY IS INTEGRAL
COMPONENT OF OUR CABINET TEAM
THEIR EXEMPLARY LEADERS THEIR
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY
UNSTOPPABLE COULDN'T BE MORE
FORTUNATE THAT TO GET TO WORK
WITH THE TWO OF THEM.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT WITH YOU I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME TO MAKE THE INTRODUCTION
WITH THAT. LET ME WELCOME
SECRETARY CASTRO WERE MERECE. I
WELCOME. HI I WANTED TO OFFER
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT YOU
WANTED TO AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE
YOUR INTRODUCED THAT MIGHT BE
WITH YOU GO AHEAD AND DO THAT-
THEY ARE YOUR ARE SOLID
SUPPORTERS OBVIOUSLY. AND THEN
GO AHEAD WITH ANY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT
INTO COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE SENATORS ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE. WITH THAT WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR ATKINS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. IT IS
AN HONOR TO BE BEFORE YOU AS
YOU CONSIDER MY APPOINTMENT. IN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO I THANK MY FAMILY. MY
HUSBAND JORGE MY DAUGHTER NOT
THAT AREA. MY SON GO TO KEEP
DAHLE. IN MY COURAGEOUS LITTLE
BOY NICHOLAS ALSO KNOWN AS THE
EAGLE WAS ALWAYS WITH ME IN
SPIRIT I FEEL HIM NOW. I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY PARENTS
THIRTY B. O. AND ONE LITTLE
THING MY SIBLINGS MY FAMILY
MEMBERS I MANY MENTORS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE JOINED US.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR LOVE.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR THEIR
SACRIFICE. IN ONE GENERATION MY
FAMILY MOVED OUT OF POVERTY AND
INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS. THIS
SLEEP WHEN. I DIGNIFIED WORK
AND DECENT WAGES A NURTURING
AND STABLE HOME ACCESS TO A
GOOD PUBLIC EDUCATION A SENSE
OF BELONGING AND A STRONG
COMMUNITY EAGLE SYSTEM THAT
OPEN MANY DOORS. I BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS THE IMPORTANT
FOUNDATION THAT ALL PEOPLE-
REQUIRE TO BE ABLE TO REACH
THEIR POTENTIAL AND THIS IS WHY
I HAVE DEDICATED MY LIFE TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. MY COMMUNITY
PLANNING AND ORGANIZING WORK IN
THE CITY OF LYNN WHAT AND
VENTURA COUNTY. COUPLED WITH MY
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP EXPERIENCE
MANAGING LARGE SCALE HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS IN THOSE SIGNED
FINANCE AND THEN SAN ANTONIO.
HAVE GIVEN ME GREATER INSIGHT
INTO WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
TACKLE SOME OF OUR COUNTRY'S
MOST PERSISTENT CHALLENGES.
DURING MY TIME WITH PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA'S ADMINISTRATION I
LET HI OFFICE OF PUBLIC IN
NATIVE AMERICAN HOUSING
PROGRAMS. AND I'VE WORKED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL STATE
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO FOSTER
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND TO
BUILD INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE
NEIGHBORHOODS. NOW I AM VERY
EXCITED TO BE BACK IN MY HOME
STATE AND I'M VERY HONORED-
THAT GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM VERY
HONORED TO WORK WITH CABINET
SECRETARY ANIMATE THE SOUND
DOES AND HIS ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION. THAT THEY HAVE
ENTRUSTED ME TO RESPONSIBILITY
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY
ASKS SECRETARY. I'M COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING STRATEGIC
LEADERSHIP WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE GOVERNOR WITH HIS ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND I WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH MY
TALENTED EXECUTIVE TEAM TO
CARRY OUT OUR MISSION IN TO
MAINTAIN A PROFESSIONAL ETHICAL
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
INCLUSIVE WORK ENVIRONMENT. OUR
AGENCY OVERSEES TWELVE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES WITH OVER
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
WHO WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
PRESERVE AND EXPAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND HOMELESSNESS
PROTECT CONSUMERS ENSURE A FAIR
MARKET PLACE AND GUARD THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. COLLECTIVELY WE
TRULY IMPACT THE LIVES OF EVERY
RESIDENT IN OUR GREAT STATE.
THE DEVASTATING THE DANCE OF
THE PAST THREE MONTHS HAVE ALSO
REVEALED DEEPLY ROOTED PROBLEMS
AND UNDERLINE INEQUITIES. LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES PEOPLE OF COLOR
WOMEN. HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CALL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WITH SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYMENT
LOSSES GREATER HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND HOUSING AND
STABILITY. AND WITH A SHARPER
FOCUS ON SCREEN IS. I AM VOTED
TO WORKING WITH YOU TO CREATE A
MORE EQUITABLE AND JUST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. I AM VERY
HUMBLED BY THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
LEAD THIS AGENCY AND TO
CONTRIBUTE TO MAKING A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND I
WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH US SECRETARY CASTRO
WERE MAYOR IS I AM GONNA AYE IF
OKAY START WITH YOU SENATOR
MONEY AND THEN WE'LL GO ROUND.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
LET ME JUST CONGRATULATE.
SECRETARY CASTRO MAYOR SON YOUR
APPOINTMENT IN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE. RECEIVING
THIS APPOINTMENT AND FOR TAKING
THE HELM DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES AS YOU MENTIONED- I DID
ENJOY OUR CHANCE TO SPEAK-
YESTERDAY IN. I THINK GAINED A
LOT OF INSIGHT- ONE AREA THAT
WE DID DISCUSS THAT I THINK
WOULD BE OF INTEREST TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC. WE DO DIRECT THE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION- ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH
YOUR AGENCY- TO ADDRESS HOUSING
ISSUES FOR HOMELESS DURING
COVERT NINETEEN- AND I THINK
ALSO FOR MIGRANT FARM WORKERS
COULD YOU JUST SHARE AN UPDATE
ON. THE DISTRIBUTION OF THAT
FUNDING AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE RESULTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED TO DATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK OU SENATOR VERY
MUCH FOR THE FOR THIS-
QUESTION- AVENUE YOU ARE.
COMPLETELY CORRECT IN OUR
AGENCY WAS ENTRUSTED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY- IN PROVIDING A
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE- TO
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
ALLOCATING THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS. APPROPRIATED.
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND MADE
AVAILABLE BY THE- AND WE I'M
I'M VERY PLEASED TO SAY THAT IN
THE PROCESS OF ALLOCATING THOSE
RESOURCES. WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH- BASE THE COUNTIES AND THE
CONTINUOUS ADD TO NOT ONLY-
PROVIDE- THE DOLLARS AND THE
DOCUMENTATION AND AGREEMENT- IN
THAT EXPEDITE- MANNER. WE ALSO-
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT- TO
ENSURE THAT APPS THEY WERE-
RESPONDING TO THE CRISIS- AND
ASKED REPORT EVERYTHING. TO
PROTECT OF THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION THAT THEY HAVE THE
TOOLS THE INFORMATION THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO RESPOND-
I'M ALSO PLEASED TO SAY THAT AB
A 100% OF THE DOLLARS ARE NOW
IN COMMUNITIES. AND HELPING- TO
CONTINUE TO MEET AND THE DRESS
AT THIS EMERGENCY. JUST BRIEFLY
WITH REGARD TO THE MIGRANTS
CENTERS- AND- YOU KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR MIKE RUN
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
PROGRAM AND THEN IN NAPLES UP
PROVIDE SAFETY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR MIGRANT WORKERS
DURING THAT THEY MAKE I HAD A
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSELY
WITH OUR SLEEP SURE. TO SHARE
THAT I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT ONE OF THE MIGRANTS
DENTURES AND YOLO COUNTY AND TO
MEET FIRST HAND WITH THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY WITH THE
RESIDENTS AND WITH A SEVERAL
SOCIAL SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT WERE PRESENT- TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE. YOU
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY AND-
WE COVERED A NUMBER OF TOPICS
THE OTHER DAY AND I AM.
CONFIDENT IN APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WANT TO THANK
YOUR FAMILY TO FIRST FOR THEIR
SUPPORT FOR YOUR WORK AND- FOR
YOUR SHARING THAT INTRODUCTION
WITH US. THIS MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING ART LET ME TURN TO
SENATOR BAKE. I THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN OUT CAN AND CONGRATS
THE BOB THE MAY HAVE CO THE
COMMENT OF MY CALL SENATOR
MONNING I AND HE SOME FIRST
REVIEW OF ODDS ARE WE HAVE TO.
I THINK VOTE ON THEIR COME ARE
YOU APPOINT AND I WILL BE DOING
THAT THAT I TO WITH FIVE MY ON
THE DURING HERE WE DID HAVE A
GREAT COMMERCE ON YESTERDAY SO
IMPRESS WITH YOU BRING TO OUR
JOB YOUR BOW. AND DOG VERY VERY
X. THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE COUPLE OF
TOP ISSUE ARE CERTAINLY HOME
AND HOUSING THAT BIGGEST LOS IN
MY DISTRICT THAT IDEA I IN OUR
COVER YESTERDAY I DO TO ALL
TALK ABOUT THE REGULATORY
RELIEF THAT WE FEEL NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN AND SURE THAT
HOUSING PROJECTS CAN BE
GENERATED A QUICKLY. AND
CERTAINLY OF THAT TO BE ON A
HOUSING BY RE SO OF THE FEES
AND THE CAR OF YOU KNOW
BUILDING SO I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
JUST SO KIND OF COMMENT ON THAT
AND HOPEFULLY OUR. I WITH YOU
BY PHONE. WITH REGARD TO ADD
HOUSING AND- THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOCUSING ON MEETING AT THIS
HOUSING CRISIS AT THAT IS BOTH-
AFFORDABILITY ARE BUT WE
DISCUSSIT'S ALSO- CONTINUING
TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
BRING MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS- THAT CHALLENGES ARE
FACING OUR STATE WHEN IT COMES
HOMELESSNESS. ARE REGULATORY
RELIEF AND STREAMLINING ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AS WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT WAYS TO INCREASE OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF AND EFFORTS AT
UNDER A DAD WOULD PROVIDE-
THROUGH EMAIL CHANGES AND LAW
AND STATUTES. TO ADDRESS AT
THIS- PARTICULAR CHALLENGE MY
COMMITMENT AS SENATOR IS TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR WERE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR I HAVE FOURTEEN
AND FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT I'M WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY AT
STREAMLINING. TO SEIZE THAT
WITH OUR SERVICE MORE SPACE AND
MORE SPOT. IN REALLY MORE. ARE
YOU JUST AN EXAMPLE WE HAVE A
TWENTY EIGHT. FUNDING PROGRAM.
AND SOME OF THEM AB ARE TO.
MAKE ACROSS AS IT. WE ARE MORE
TOWARDS LOOKING AT TO
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS AGAIN
YOU GOT TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
SUPPORT AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
ENABLES US TO PRESERVE. PROTECT
AND EXPAND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT IS GREAT
TO HEAR IT AND- IT'S MUSIC TO
MY EARS WHEN YOU SAY THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CONTINUE SIDE A
LITTLE WING ARE SOME OF THE
FUNDS THAT ARE AVAILABLE- THAT
HE IS ALWAYS A PROBLEM AND IT
REALLY STRICT THE ARE THE MEDIA
AT TOWN. DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE VERY VERY CRITICAL ISSUE
SO ODD BY WHICH WOULD TELL. THE
JOB THAT TIME I KNOW THERE
REALLY UP TO IT AND I ALSO KNOW
FROM OUR CONVERSATION A YEAR
REALLY EXCITED TO PURSUE A SOLO
YOU WILL MY SUPPORT AND- NO.
FOR PER STATION WE MOVED. INTO
IT THIS. THING ISSUE FOR OUR
STATE HAVE LAST NIGHT HOUSING
THANKS AGAIN. THE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES LET ME TURN NOW
TO THE VICE CHAIRMAN MISTER
WILL. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
AND- SECRETARY- CASTER ROMERO'S
CONGRATULATIONS. ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AT THE PROPER TIME
I LOOK FORWARD TO WHILE PUTTING
FORTH- HERE- CONFIRMATION
NOMINATION I JUST I SIMPLY HAVE
HAVE ONE QUESTION AS WE AS
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AND PANDEMIC OF COURSE
TERRY FOR ALL OF US. BY THE WAY
YOUR TIMING'S EVERYTHING IN
POLITICS I JUSTIT'S JUST A
GOOD BASS CITY TO ME THAT YOU
CAME. RIGHT AT GROUND ZERO BUT
YOU KNOW GOING THROUGH THIS IT
IT'S IN AGAIN WE'RE FLYING BY
SUPER PASS A LOT OF AREAS BUT
SEEMS TO ME A LOT OF THIS SEEMS
TO BE ARBITRARY. DECISIONS THAT
IN MAY THAN ONE THIS SEEMS
ARBITRARY TO ME AND TO MANY OF
MY CONSTITUENTS. IS WHEN
GOVERNOR CAME OUT IN EARLY MAY
AND SAID THAT THE FIRST A
COMMUNITY SPREAD WAS AT A NAIL
SALON. PEOPLE THAT GO TO THEIR
LICENSURE PROCESS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH HEALTH AND SAFETY THEY
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND NOW THIS IS A SOMETHING
THAT STAGE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY. AND I THINK WE ARE
ALL AWARE THAT. THE
ENTREPRENEURS IN THIS INDUSTRY-
LARGELY IMMIGRANT MINORITY AND
FEMALE OWNED AND IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE BURDEN- ON ON ON
THESE PEOPLE SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS SO YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE IN TERMS OF THAT.
AND WHAT IF ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO MAKE COMMANDS AND OR HELP-
THESE THESE PEOPLE IN THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
SENATOR YOU ARE CORRECT I SHARE
YOUR CONCERN THAT THE FINANCIAL
STRAIN AND THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THAT THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN AB PANDEMIC HAS COST.
NATIONALS AND LICENSEES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE AND AS YOU
MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY- ARE OUT
AND BOARD AS I BARBERENA HAND
AND COSMETOLOGY DAD REGULATE
AND THEY'LL SHOPS AND BEAUTY
SALONS HAS BEEN AN INDUSTRY
IMPACTED- LIKE MANY OTHERS. I
WANT TO REASSURE YOU THAT- OUR
APPROACH HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO BE
VERY COLLABORATIVE WITH- EVERY
SINGLE INDUSTRY AND- THE
VARIOUS- BUSINESSES THAT- ARE
LICENSED THROUGH OUR DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND WE YOU
KNOW RECOGNIZE THAT. IN SOME
CASES THERE HAS BEEN CONFUSION
ABOUT WHEN- CERTAIN BUSINESSES
KENO ARE ABLE TO OPEN OR NOT-
OUR OUR APPROACH HAS BEEN TO
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH. OUR
PARTNERS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- TO DEVELOP YOUR
GUIDANCE TO WORK THROUGH OUR
BOARDS IN THE URALS TO
COMMUNICATE TO LICENSEES. IN
TWO AND FRANKLY TO BE AVAILABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE AND SO AS WE
BEGAN TO. RE OPEN THE ECONOMY
IS THIS YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
A VERY THOUGHTFUL METHODICAL
PROCESS TO DOING THAT. AND THAT
WE ARE FULLY ENGAGE IN
CONNECTICUT. AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO DO. THAT IT IT WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING IN THE WAY
THAT ENABLES- SMALL BUSINESSES
BEAUTY SALONS- IS OUT YOU KNOW
THAT LICENSEE POPULATION THAT
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR REGULATING
TO DO SO IN IN THE WAY THAT
ENABLES THEM TO BE ABLE TO- TO
RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND
AGAIN I WANT AYE AYE ONE ECHO
THE PRIOR POSITIVE COMMENTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUES. STATED AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YEAR- CON- CONFIRMATION WHEN I
MOVE IT AND IT COMES UP FOR A
VOTE. IN HERE. SENATOR ROBB
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM A
CONGRATULATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
I ABSOLUTELY HAVE NO QUESTIONS
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU- I HAVE
A- MAYBE JUST A BRIEF QUESTION
AND- AND IT'S SO GOOD TO GET A
CHANCE TO TALK WITH YOU- GIVEN-
THE WAY WE ARE HAVING TO WORK
THESE DAYS AREN'T REMOTELY. YOU
OVERSEE MANY OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO- TO SO MANY OF US HOUSING-
OF FAIR HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT-
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SO MANY THINGS AND
BY THE WAY. I WILL SAY- FROM MY
DISTRICT PERSPECTIVE THEY DID
WELL WITH- THE DEPARTMENT OF
ACT OF BEVERAGE CONTROL ON A
DAILY BASIS IN THE BALANCE THAT
DEPARTMENT REALLY. CLOSE TO
MEET ENTER PROVIDE BUSINESS
LICENSES. INPUT IS DID PAUL BUT
I HAVE TO SAY I EVEN YESTERDAY.
I GET COMPLIMENTS ON THE STREET
IN SACRAMENTO FROM SOME
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT SO I THOUGHT I WOULD
PUBLICLY SHARE THAT. I
QUESTIONS IN THE ROLE THAT WE
PLAY HERE. AND AS THE RULES
COMMITTEE TO CONFIRM
APPOINTMENTS- MANY OF THOSE
APPOINTMENTS ARE OUR
APPOINTMENTS NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ON LIKE YOURS AS THE
SECRETARY ARM AND SOMETIMES
WITH THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHERE WE DO NOT
HAVE TO HEAR THOSE APPOINTMENTS
IT THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR UNLESS THERE IS-
COMPLAINTS MADE ABOUT THE WAY
SOME OF THOSE BOARDS I INTERACT
WITH THE PUBLIC. SO I WAS
HOPING TO GET YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PUBLIC
PROTECTION ROLE OF THE CONSUMER
THEIR DEPARTMENT AND KILLER HOW
DO YOU BACK STAKEHOLDER IN THIS
WHICH USUALLY HAS A LOT MORE
RESOURCES MONEY LEGAL COUNSEL
EXPERIENCE VERSUS SAY THE
PUBLIC PROTECT. I THOSE WHO
PROBABLY HAVE LESS RESOURCES
INFLUENCE ARE IN THOSE CASES
AND IF THERE IS A BALANCE. YOU
KNOW HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU LOOK
AT THAT- THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT
WILL CERTAINLY COME TO YOUR
ATTENTION IF THEY HAVEN'T
ALREADY THEY COME TO OUR
ATTENTION FROM WE GET LETTERS
OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT UP. KILLER
APPOINTMENTS TO SOME OF THOSE
CONSUMER PROTECTION BOARD SO
JUST A FEW MINUTES OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON ON THAT. DEPARTMENT
IN PARTICULAR AND HOW YOU HOW
YOU PERCEIVE THAT ROLE OF
PUBLIC INTEREST. THANK YOU
MADAM I HAVE AFTER TEN AND ADD
TO THE CHAIR WOMAN AND I WILL
ALSO PASS ALONG THE MESSAGE TO-
JAKE UP IN ABC AND IT HAS
ENTIRE TEAM IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU HAVE JUST SHARED IN TERMS
OF THE POSITIVE COMMENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER FIRST I
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT-
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE AGENCY
ARE JUST OVER THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES- RESPONSIBLE FOR-
REGULATING AND SUPPORTING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS. ARE AND
I- IT IT IS- A VERY
SIGNIFICANT- DEPARTMENT- WITH-
VERY- IN A VERY. IMPORTANT ROLE
AS IT RELATES TO GOVERNANCE AS
IT RELATES TO REGULATING. IT
RELATES TO ENFORCEMENT AND- IT
ALSO AS IT RELATES TO- EDUCATE
AND GREATER AWARENESS. OUT WE
HAVE- A VERY TALENTED AND
CAPABLE LEADER AND CURRENTLY
LEADING THAT THE PART OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS IN. MINOR I
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH. EXTEND PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE CALL THAT
NINETEEN AND PANDEMIC WE WORKED
ON THE NUMBER OF EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AT TO AUGMENT-
AND TO AND TO ASSIST WITH THE
HEALTH SEARCH- GIVEN SOME OF
THE LESSONS HE POPULATION. AND
I WOULD SAY THAT AS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STAY FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING CONSUMERS ARE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO. STREAMLINE
AND IMPROVE OUR SERVICE AND- AS
WE BEGIN TO THINK THROUGH THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY- VIEW THAT-
MANY WAYS FIRST THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT. TWO FIVE FLEXING TO
ENABLE LICENSEES TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AND EXERCISE OF THEIR- WE
ARE LOOKING- MADAM CHAIR AT
WAYS TO INCORPORATE SOME OF
THOSE LESSONS- SPECIFICALLY- WE
HAVE- RECOGNIZE THAT. THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT LICENSE
YOU CAN DO I WITH THE USE OF
ONLINE TRAINING AND TECHNOLOGY.
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS
TO BE MORE LASER FOCUSED ON
THAT. AGAIN YOU KNOW CONTINUING
TO STRIKE THE BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. PROVIDING
AND IT FORCES INTO ORDER. ARE
AND THEN ALSO REALLY SERVING AS
A PARTNER IN PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION GEN. TO
MEET. I GUESS THE JOB JUST
DON'T BIT ON THAT. THE BALANCE
OF PUBLIC PROTECTION I IT YOU
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO AN
INSTITUTION LIKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT APPROVES THOSE
LICENSES- VERSUS AN INDIVIDUAL
THAT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. BEFORE ANY OF THE MANY
BOARDS I DON'T I DON'T EVEN
FRANKLY KNOW HOW MANY BOARDS.
ALL UNDER THE DIRECTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BUT- MAYBE YOUR PERSPECTIVE IN
TERMS OF THAT BALANCE WHEN IT
COMES TO. YOU KNOW THE LICENSEE
VERSUS THE PROTECTION OF PUBLIC
CONSUMERS I SEE I SEE I AND I
UNDERSTAND THE AT THAT THE
VARIOUS BOARDS AND YOU'RE ALL
SET ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR AND-
FOR APPROVING- CHANGES- TO. ADD
THE- WE ARE ALSO STANDARD AND
THIS IS YOU KNOW FRANKLY- AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE. YOU KNOW
TAT THAT THAT WE ARE CREATING
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT ALLOWS FOR
ENGAGEMENT FROM LICENSEES
STARBOARD MEETINGS ARE PUBLIC
BOARD MEETINGS THAT ENABLE
LICENSEES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FEEDBACK. DURING I JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE ALSO DURING THE CALL
WITH NINETEEN ON PANDEMIC ASKED
WE WERE- DEVELOPING GUIDANCE
PROVIDING GREATER FLEXIBILITY-
HE- MADE SURE TO PROVIDE WHAT
WE CALL FOR THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
ENABLED- LICENSEES- TO CALL IN
TO- NOT ONLY ARE WE SEE THE
PATIENT THAT ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION. AND I THINK THAT
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US FOR
ARE YOU LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING. WITH YOU AND DIVERT
THE LEGISLATURE TO FIND A WAY.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE IN
TERMS OF ENGAGE MEN AND- ENSURE
THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE YOU KNOW
CONTINUING TO STATE RESPONSIVE
ENABLE. INSTEAD TO OUR LICENSEE
POPULATION. THANK YOU SECRETARY
THANK YOU SO MUCH- IF NO OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WHO ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SECRETARY
CASTRO WERE MERIT. AND WE WILL
START OUR ANY BUSINESSES THAT
MIGHT BE HERE IN ROOM. THIRTY
NINETY ONE. I ASK YOU TO
FORWARD AND I. ONLY WANTED THE
TIME. EXCUSE ME TO ENSURE
SOCIAL DISTANCING- WELCOME IF
YOU WOULD GIVE ME YOUR NAME-
WHO YOU MIGHT REPRESENT IF
ANYONE OTHER THAN YOURSELF AND
BRIEF COMMENTS WELCOME. YOU SO
MUCH A GOOD MORNING OR
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VANESSA
AND I'M REPRESENTING HOLD HIS
FINANCE ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY. TODAY I WILL BE
READING A FEW REMARKS FROM HOPE
C. E. O. HELEN TOUR IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
ALERT IS CASTRO. FALLEN RIGHT.
I FIRST MET MISS CUSTOMER MERIT
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN SHE
PARTICIPATED IN HOPES
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE OUR
FLAGSHIP PROGRAM FOR
ACCOMPLISHED LATINO
PROFESSIONALS. THROUGH HER
JOURNEY SERVING IN LOS ANGELES
DENTAL NAIL AND AS PART OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
ADMINISTRATION SHE HAS THIRD
WITH TECH READY AND BOLD
LEADERSHIP. BECAUSE OF HER LONG
STANDING TRACK RECORD AS AN
EFFECTIVE EXECUTIVE AND
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE I
NOW MISS CATCHER MAYORS WILL
LEAD WITH INTEGRITY AND ENSURE
THAT RESULTS WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY MORE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN FROM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE PHYSICALLY- AND BROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET ME
ASK ABOUT OUR ROOM ONE TWELVE.
FOR PURPOSES OF ENSURING THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY WITH THAT I WE
WILL NOW TURN ON. TO THE THOSE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE OF THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
SO I KNOW THAT WE HAVE-
MODERATOR AND IF YOU WOULD.
JOIN US AND PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SECRETARY CASTRO
WERE MERECE. CERTAINLY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN ON THE AUDIO
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YOU MAY DO
SO AT THIS TIME BY PRESSING ONE
TEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. PLEASE ALLOW US A FEW
MOMENTS.
WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TIFFANY FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. TEX MEX WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
DANIEL COULD SHARE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SECRETARY COVERAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THANKS WITNESSES LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE ATKINS AND
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
THIS IS CHRIS WE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES COUNTY
HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESS
SERVICES- ON THAT ARE
INCREASINGLY- HUGE FOCUS OF THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER. SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE APPOINTMENT OF
SECRETARY CASTRO OR MIRRORS AND
HER CONFIRMATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WITNESS AND NEXT
WITNESSES LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SECRETARIES
CONFIRMATION WILL YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AGAIN FOR THE
RECORD WE DIDN'T GET IT. ARE
YOU THERE KIMBERLY DADDY. BUT
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE. OKAY I
LET'S GIVE IT A MOMENT AND MAKE
SURE NO ONE ELSE IS CALLING IN
AND THEN WE WILL. MOVE FORWARD.
MISTER MODERATOR WE CHECK ONE
LAST TIME. WELL LAST TIME IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PUT YOURSELF IN
THE KILLING SUPPORT IT'S ONE
THEN ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR. OKAY
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. WILL BEGIN IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- WITH A
REMINDER ONE PERSON AT A TIME
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APPOINTMENT. SEEING NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION- FOR PURPOSES OF
PROCESS WE WILL MOVE MOVED TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS. NO FURTHER WITNESSES
THERE. SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR I WILL COME BACK TO
YOU TO OPEN THE LINES AND SEE
IF THERE IS ANY WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPOINTMENT.
PLEASE ENTER THEM IN ON THE
AUDIO. PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING
UP AT THIS TIME. MISTER
MODERATOR FOR YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND HELP LET ME
BRING IT BACK TO- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN SO MOVED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BATES RIGHT IF I
MONNING ALL RIGHT ON IN I ROTH
AYE ROTH AYE WILK HI LOOK I
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE
CONGRATULATIONS THE SECRETARY
CHARACTER MERRY'S IT'S
UNANIMOUS. YEAH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. OKAY WE WILL
LET ME CHECK IN AND MAKE SURE
ARE ARE STILL NOT REFER IS OKAY
AND DOESN'T NEED A BREAK IF I
CAN GET SOME- HI SIGN FROM.
WE'RE GOOD OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL- TAKE UP THE NEXT
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
MISS YOLANDA ARE RICHARDSON-
WELCOME. AND YOU HAD A YOU HAD
A INTRODUCTION OBVIOUSLY BY ON
A MONTH TO SIGN POST AS WELL-
SO WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU. TO
BE WITH US TODAY ASK IF YOU
WANT TO RECOGNIZE ANYONE- WITH
YOU ARE OR THAT YOU WOULD
ESPECIALLY LIKE TO POINT OUT
AND THEN MAKE ANY OPENING%
COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
THE QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
SENATORS. WELCOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU QUITE WELL. AWESOME
THANK YOU MADAM FOR TEN.
SENATORS AND STAFF OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET WITH YOU ALL TODAY AND
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
APPOINTMENT- I'D FIRST LIKE TO
START BY THANKING MY AMAZING
HAS BEEN OF TWENTY THREE YEARS.
SANYO ARE WONDERFUL CHILDREN
MAKE AN ENGINE A FOR THEIR LOVE
AND SUPPORT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE GREAT TEAM I'VE GOT A
LOT. ALL OF THE DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY. AND THE HOST OF FRIENDS
AND COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
OFFERED THEIR INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT TO ME. I ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE. ONE ON A SONG FOR
HER OPENING REMARKS TODAY AND
FOR ALL OF HER SPORT. BOB
INSPIRE BY THE WAY I HAD AND
THE- AND PUBLIC SECTORS. BUT
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THE WORK
AND THE EXPERIENCE. THAT I HAD
IT COVERED CALIFORNIA. IT
OPENED MY EYES TO THE
POSSIBILITIES OF THE REWARDS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE. AND I WANTED TO
DUPLICATE THAT SUCCESS ACROSS
THE STATE. WHEN I STARTED A
LITTLE OVER TWELVE WEEKS AGO
HAD THREE GOALS IN MIND.
ADVANCING STRATEGIES THAT
SUPPORT GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCIES
EXPANDING GOVERNMENT INNOVATION
AND CONTRIBUTING TO A
GOVERNMENT THAT WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WOULD HAVE
NEVER PREDICTED THAT I WOULD
FIND MYSELF- ON DAY TWO IN THE
MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
WITH THE CHARGE TO LEAD THE
TRANSITION OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF STATE EMPLOYEES. TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO WORK FROM
HOME I DEVELOPING POLICIES
PROCEDURES AND GUIDANCE TO
ENSURE THAT WE COULD ALL
MONITOR AND SAFEGUARD DATA. AS
WE INTRODUCE NEW PLATFORMS FOR
WORKING MEETING. ADDITIONALLY I
WOULD HAVE NEVER HAVE IMAGINED
HELPING TO LEAD WHILE TRYING TO
PROCESS THE IMPLICATIONS. WHAT
WE ALL SAW THE WORLD IN
RESPONSE TO THE DEATH OF MISTER
GEORGE FLOYD AND WHAT IT MEANT
TO ME AND FAMILY. ALL WHILE
TRYING TO CONTINUE TO FULFILL
MY ROLE AS SECRETARY. BUT WITH
CHALLENGES- OPPORTUNITIES AND-
SAME GOALS I CAME TO GOV OPS TO
ACHIEVE. ARE NOW MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER BEFORE TO ME. OUR
TEAM A DEVOPS AND THE
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE AGENCY
WILL BE FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EFFICIENCIES
AND A TIME THAT ARE BUDGET
DEMANDS. LEVERAGING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND XCELERATED
INNOVATION TO REDUCE
REDUNDANCY. REVEALING POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO ENSURE THAT
EQUITY AND INCLUSION IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ALL WE DO. AND
THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN ACCESS
AND BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES
WE OFFER. LOADING I'D LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR THIS
AWESOME OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA. A SECRETARY MY
PRIORITY IS TO PUSH INTO DRIVE
AND TO ELEVATE OUR POTENTIAL TO
MAKE GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT WORK
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. I'M CLEAR
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD BUT I REMAIN COMMITTED TO
THE GOALS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
ACHIEVE. A LOOK FORTY FASHION
THANK YOU SECRETARY WE WILL
START SENATOR ROBB WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MODE MATTER PRO
TEMPORE MEDICINE KATERI
CONGRATULATIONS. I AM VERY VERY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR RESUME AND
YOUR RECORD AND I CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
YOU AT THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS MAN APPROACHED HIM
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
THIS CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE TO MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND- THANK YOU SO
MUCH MATTER SECRETARY- I TO
LOOK FOR TO. BODY FOR YOUR
CONFIRMATION. OKAY A COUPLE
QUESTIONS I GUESS SO ONE. I
HAVEN'T READ THE GOVERNOR'S
BOOKS CITIZEN BILL WHICH WHICH
IS WAS DURING HIS TIME AS MAYOR
FOR HEAT HE TOOK A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND DATA AND
PROGRAMS ON THE ONLINE SIFTED
POWER CITIZENS. AND I'M- BUT
BELIEVE ME BECAUSE THIS
PANDEMIC WE'RE GONNA TRY TO BE
PUTTING A LOT MORE THINGS
ONLINE- WITH MY COLLEAGUE HERE
SAID A ROUGH AND I WE USED TO
SET A BUDGET SUB FOR WHERE WE
WOULD HEAR HORROR STORY AFTER
HORROR STORY- THESE I. T.
PLATFORMS AND NOT NOT WORKING.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS. DO
YOU BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD PREPARE FOR
POTENTIAL ON SET OF NEW IT
PROJECTS AND WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO TO GUARANTEE THAT THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL. ABSOLUTE QUESTION
YES THEY SHOULD PREPARE FOR
THAT- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAS BEEN- INTRODUCED IT IS A
PROCESS CALLED THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY HAS REALIZE SOME
SUCCESSES WITH USING THAT
PROCESS WITH IT PROJECTS AS WE
ALL KNOW IN GOVERNMENT THERE'S
A LOT OF STORIES ABOUT WHAT DID
YOU WORK BUT WHAT I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU IS THE LAST ONE E. I.
T. PROJECTS THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY HAS
HAD OVERSIGHT FOR THAT HAS
UTILIZED THIS PROJECT. AKANE
IN- BUDGET WITH A NO CREEP
SINCE GO AND NO EDITIONS TO
THAT TO THE TO THE BUDGET OUR
SCHEDULE IS SO I THINK WE'VE
NOW INTRODUCED A MODEL OF THAT
CAN WORK FOR AYE CHIEF PROJECTS
GOING FORWARD BUT THAT WON'T BE
ENOUGH- WE'VE GOT A LEVERAGE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND INNOVATION
I AM VERY PROUD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ENTRUSTED ME
WITH LEADERSHIP THE ALL OF
DIGITAL IN THE NATION AND JUST
READ WE USE A NEW AFTER A TWO
THAT. AND WE WILL BE WORKING
AND PARTNERING WITH DEPARTMENTS
TO INTRODUCE THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT DIGITAL INNOVATION GREAT I
THINK WE SHOULD OWN SOME
EXAMPLES MOST RECENTLY OF THE
CARPET NINETEEN DOT CA DOT GOV
WEBSITE WHAT WE HAVE A SINGLE
REPOSITORY FOR ACT AS WELL ALL
CALIFORNIANS. FIND OUT IN.
PROCESS OF SIX AND ONE
PARTICULAR LOOK. AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR DO WHAT THAT ACROSS
THE- AND I'M ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU- ON CONTINUING TO HAVE SOME
SUCCESSES. GRADE A THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO I DON'T KNOW WHERE
STANDS RIGHT NOW BUT BEFORE WE
WALKED IN THE DOW WAS DOWN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED POINTS TODAY.
AND I'VE GOT A QUESTION FROM
ONE OF MY SENATE COLLEAGUES WHO
WANTED ME TO ASK THIS SO HOW DO
YOU EXERCISE OVERSIGHT OVER
CALPERS IN CANISTERS AND WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT THE
AGENCY CAN BE OF HELP WITH KELP
PERSON CANCERS FUNDING PROBLEMS.
WELL AS YOU MAY KNOW CALPERS
AND CAL STORES OR ITS HAPPY
JUDICIARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEIR RESPECTIVE FUNDS. BUT I
ENJOY A VERY CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS. HELPING
THEM TO IN ANY WAY WE CAN
ESPECIALLY WITH THEIR STATE.
WORKFORCE IN INFRASTRUCTURE-
THE AGENCY HERE ALSO CAN BE
LEVERAGE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS-
TO HELP INTRODUCE FUNDING
POLICIES. AND THEN OF COURSE
PARTNERED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- AND WITH THOSE ARE
DEPARTMENTS. I TO INTRODUCE OUR
FUNDING POLICIES TO THE BUDGET
A LEGISLATIVE. PROCESS SO
THAT'S HOW WE MAINTAIN THAT
RELATIONSHIP AND I HAVE REALLY
ENJOYED- BOTH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS IN THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
I'M IN MY FIRST FEW WEEKS. HERE
I APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERS AND
AGAIN LOOKING FORWARD TO VOTING
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER BY
CHAIRMAN SENATOR BATES. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN. AND MISS
RICHARDSON AYE AYE AND LOOKING
AROUND BECAUSE LIKE. BUT WE HAD
A GREAT CONVERSATION YESTERDAY
ON THE COLLEAGUES OF REGARDING
WHAT THE NEW SECRETARY IS GOING
TO DO TO ADDRESS THE STATE
EMPLOYEE NEED SOME FOR REMOTE
AND- WHAT THE NEW NORMAL IS
GOING TO MEAN IN TERMS OF THE
STATE AS FAR AS OFFICE SPACE IN
REAL ESTATE NEED TIME TO HAND
OUT HOW THAT WILL HELP OUT. THE
MANAGERS OF DEPARTMENTS AND YOU
KNOW WORKING WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES SO I'D LIKE A THANK
YOU LAW SECRETARY RICHARDSON IF
YOU JUST TO OUR SHARE BRIEFLY-
WHAT YOU ARE DOING TO PROVIDE
STATE EMPLOYEES WITH THE RIGHT
TOOLS TO WORK FROM HOME. AND
HOW WE ARE MONITORING OUR TO
ENSURE WORK IS PERFORMED AND
THEY'RE STILL RECOGNIZE STOP
FOR ALL CERTAINLY BOB I FEEL
SAD AND IMPROVING ON THEIR OF
THEIR WORK SO THAT THEY'RE
MOVING TOWARDS YOU KNOW HIGHER
LOG. QUALITY AND PROBABLY SAT
JOB SATISFACTION BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT INTERACTION FACE TO FACE
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES AND I
THINK YOU SPOKE CAUGHT ABOUT
THAT AND YOU'RE- TAKING A LOOK
HOW THAT HAPPENED ALSO. SENATOR
BASE AND WE ATE ENJOY OUR
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. AND I
THINK IT'S A BALANCE WHY WE
KNOW THAT THEIR ARE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY AND ADVANTAGES. OF
REMORSE REMOTE WORK WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT GOING FORWARD IT
WILL- BECAUSE US OR GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT HOW
TO WE SPORT. NOT ONLY ARE
WORKERS BUT ALSO THOSE THAT
MANAGE THOSE WORKERS AND SO WE
ARE LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
THINGS. TRAINING FOR REMOTE
WORKERS SO THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND HOW TO
LEVERAGE THAT CERTAINLY HOW TO
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE WORKING IN
A HOME ENVIRONMENT. MANAGERS
AND HOW THEY CAN MANAGED OUR
CONSTANT YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
GET TO SEE WHO'S DOING THE WORK
EVERY DAY- BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
BALANCE OF. ENSURING THAT WE
GIVE TECHNIQUE. PARTIES CAN
MAINTAIN COAL. LIEUTENANT IT NO
ONE FOUR ONE VOICE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ALTHOUGH I MAY
BE TALKING TO YOU ONE THREE I
STE ALONG. WORK. I DON'T
CONNECT TO THAT. AND MY
COLLEAGUE THIS YEAR. WAYS OF
HOW THEY DO THE YOUR NEWSLETTER.
AND LEE TELL. CHATS WITH THEIR
ENTIRE DEPART. AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO COLLECT THOSE THAT'S
PRACTICES. AND SHARING STATE
WHY SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT OUR
STATE WORKFORCE IS NORMAL. WELL
THANK YOU AND VERY IMPRESSED ON
THAT THAT WAS ALREADY UNDER WAY
SO. YOU'LL HAVE MY STRONG
SUPPORT TO- WIND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS
SITE. REALLY SIGNIFICANT- RULE
YOU'RE GOING TO PLAY HERE FOR
OUR GOVERNMENT THANKS AGAIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANT TO ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU MADAM SECRETARY ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT IN. THANK YOU FOR
STEPPING UP COMMENCED OR WOULD
NINETEEN CRISIS- I ALSO
APPRECIATED OUR OPPORTUNITY TO.
SPEAK AT SOME LENGTH ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES ONE AREA OF
INTEREST IS ON THE CENSUS
TWENTY TWENTY- THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED. A HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
CENSUS OFFICE- THAT IS UNDER
THE- SUPERVISION OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY-
CAN YOU GIVE US A BRIEF UPDATE
ABOUT. HOW THAT OVERSIGHT IS
WORKING AND WHAT IF ANY
ADAPTATIONS HAVE HAD TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE OF WHAT WOULD NINETEEN.
I KNOW THE GOAL OF CALIFORNIANS
TO TRY TO FILL SOME OF OUR
REACH GAPS THAT. WE DON'T FEEL
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OUT
REACH IS. IS COMMITTED TO SELL
HOW DO WE HANDLE THAT WITH
COVERT NINETEEN THANK YOU. SURE
SENATOR MODEL THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YES IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT THE COLD BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. DID PUT A HALT TO ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TECHNIQUES THAT WE KNOW HAPPENS
WITH THE CENSUS AND THAT'S OUR
FIELD OPERATIONS. HOWEVER I
REALLY COMMEND ESPECIALLY-
DURING THE TIME WHEN WE HERE AT
THE AGENCY WAS SO FOCUSED ON ON
THE PANDEMIC UP FOCUSED ON
LOOKING AT ALTERNATE TECHNIQUES
REACHING- COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES ARE CREATIVE WAYS
OF LEVERAGING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAD. SOME OF THE
APPROACHES THAT HAVE COME ABOUT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC- AND
KEEPING UP THE PRESSURE ON WITH
REGARD TO INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. FOR ONE TO
FILL OUT THE CENSUS WE ARE
ANXIOUSLY WAITING FOR THE US
CENSUS BUREAU TO UP THE
NUMERATORS IN THE BILL BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE. METHOD OF FOR PEOPLE
TO LEARN ABOUT THIS SINCE. I'M
IN ADDITION WE ARE BEFORE I
REACH PARTNERS WHO ARE RIGHT
NOW COMING UP WITH STRATEGIES
THAT WILL COMPLEMENT THOSE IN
RAIDERS. ALL YOU DON'T ALWAYS
THIS IS ALL HAN ON DECK. AND WE
REALLY OF. THE END. OF OTHERS
ON. THIS TECHNIQUES THAT WE CAN
USE AND LEVERAGE ARE TO REACH
ALL COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES COLOR- IN OUR
IMMIGRANTS COMMUNITIES SO-
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU IN IN JUST A SHORT
FOLLOW UP ON. AS THAT MONEY
GOES OUT TO SOME LOCAL.
AGENCIES OR ORGANIZATIONS. TO
IMPLEMENT- THE STATE'S
OBJECTIVES ON THE CENSUS OUT
REACH. OUT HOW IS YOUR OFFICE
MAINTAINING OVERSIGHT TO THOSE
EXPENDITURES. TO REMAINING
MONIES THAT HAVEN'T YET GONE
OUT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
WE- HAVE- KIND ENOUGH FORCE ARE
OUT OF REACH PARTNERS RIGHT
NOW- ARE TURNING IN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS AND BEING
REVIEWED- FOR. OUR MEDIA
PARTNER HAS COMMITTED IT- THE
REMAINING FUNDS IN THAT
CONTRACT TO ACTIVITIES TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPAIGN THROUGH
AUGUST- THE CENSUS OFFICE WILL
BE LAUNCHING A- DATA. OUR
DASHBOARD NEXT WEEK THAT WILL
HELP ALL OF US TRACK THE ACTUAL
ACTIVITIES IN THE FIELD AND HOW
THOSE ACT THOSE OUTCOMES ARE-
RESULTING IN AND OUT. OF
RESPONSE RATE SO I'M WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ADD SOME MORE
INFORMATION AND ASKED ME IF YOU
KNOW AS WE GET IT BUT WE KNOW
THAT THIS AGAIN IT'S ALL HANDS
ON DECK AND WE HOPE THAT ON THE
MECHANISM THAT WORK BUT HE TOOK
PLACE. WELL ENHANCE THE
OVERSIGHT HAS BEEN HAPPENING SO
FAR. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
AND AGAIN I'LL LOOK FOR
DEVOTING FOR YOU AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU FIVE
SENATOR MINING. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AT THIS
VERY- TO CONTINUE TO SERVE I
SHOULD SAY IN THIS NEW ROLE I
YOUR AND AN INCREDIBLY-
DIFFICULT TIME ON SO MANY
FRONTS AND CERTAINLY I AGREE
WITH MR VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE I.
T. WORLD ALONE IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU HAVE TO OVERSEE FOR A STATE
THE SIZE OF CALIFORNIA AND
OBVIOUSLY COMING FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA. WHICH I BELIEVE TO
BE A VERY SUCCESSFUL- PROGRAM-
THAT THE STATE EMBRACED EARLY
ON- AND DID SO VERY DIRECT WITH
COMMUNITY. WAY THAT I THINK I
MADE IT INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL
ALWAYS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT BUT
A VERY IMPRESSIVE. I ENDEAVOR
ON THE PART OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
GONNA. JUST FOLLOW ALONG
SENATOR MINING'S OUR COMMENTS
BECAUSE- THE- BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE- REALLY JUMPED
IN VERY QUICKLY ON THE COMPLETE
COUNT. AND THE CENSUS PROGRAM
GOT VERY BUSY AT WORK MY- BOTH
MY REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES ALIKE HAVE BEEN
INVESTED IN MAKING SURE- THAT
WE ARE PARTNERS ON THE GROUND
IT IS A LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE AND
THEREFORE WERE ABLE TO DO ALL
OF THIS WORK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS BUT A I THINK YOU'RE
QUITE AWARE AS YOU STEP INTO
THIS ROLE THAT THERE'S BEEN A
GREAT DEAL OF FRUSTRATION.
BECAUSE THE STATE REALLY
STEPPED UP- ARE A WITH A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR. SINCE THIS
OUTRAGE THE KEY AT TARGETED
COMMUNITIES AND I JUST WANNA
UNDERSCORE THE FACT THAT. WE
NOW KNOW THAT CONTRACTS ARE
BEING REVISITED DUE TO THE
THREE MONTH EXTENSION. AND THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE NOT WHERE ARE
THEY WERE COMPARED ABLE TO-
TWENTY TEN. AND THERE'S A LOT
OF REASONS FOR THAT IS VERY
CLEAR OBVIOUSLY BUT IN TERMS OF
A DIET ADJUSTING AND FIGURED
OUT. A BETTER WAY TO REACH
THOSE. NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UPS-
WHICH WILL TAKE PLACE IN AUGUST
AUGUST- THROUGH OCTOBER. REALLY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE PLAN IS
ON TIMING AND DISTRIBUTING
THOSE FUNDS AND ENSURING THAT
THEY GET TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REACH THOSE COMMUNITIES WHICH I
KNOW YOU COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
TRANSLATES INTO DOLLARS FOR
CALIFORNIA. I THAT WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE GOING TO NEED ESPECIALLY
NOW SO. REALLY WANT A
COMMITMENT THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE LOOKED AT- AND THE
CONCERNS OF THE SENATORS ARE
COLLEAGUES I HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD. THAT I THESE DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO GET WHERE THEY
NEED TO GO ON THE GROUND TO DO
THAT WORK AND- JUST KIND OF
WANTED YOUR REACTION TO THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT THIS.
ABSOLUTELY AND I HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- YOUR YOUR
COMMENT- AT APPROACH HIM. WE
ARE THAT DEFINITELY LOOKING AT
THAT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS AND THE WORK AND THE
COLLABORATION AND THE INPUT-
FROM THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS- ONE
OF THE PRIMARY FOCUS FOR ME IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS WAS TO GET
UP TO SPEED. AND WE RECOGNIZE
WE HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE US LET ME TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT OUR APPROACH IN OUR
TECHNIQUES GOING FORWARD.
CERTAINLY WE HAVE THE US CENSUS
BUREAU DATA WHICH SHOWS AS
WHERE WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO
IN TERMS OF LOW RESPONSE RATE
AND SO WE'RE NEARING OUR
STRATEGIES AND OUR FOCUS WITH
THERE ARE WHICH PARTNERS. TO
THOSE CENSUS TRACKS- AND WE
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
IS TEN MILLION DOLLARS LEFT AND
WE WANT TO ALLOCATE AT LEAST
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. IF YOU
ARE OUTRAGE PARTNERS TO
CONTINUE THEIR EFFORTS I
ESPECIALLY WITH THE EXTENSION
OF THE CENSUS CAMPAIGN- A
STRATEGY THAT WE THINK WILL BE
VERY BENEFICIAL FOR ALL OF US
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK. IS
HOLDING BACK SOME DOLLARS SO
WHEN THOSE LAST FEW MONTHS WHEN
IT'S SO CRITICAL IF WE NEED TO
MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS OR WE NEED
TO TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT OR
WE NEED TO FIND COMPLEMENTARY.
TECHNIQUES ARE HIS I WILL THE
FINANCE RESOURCES TO DO SO- IN
ADDITION- LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DO HAVE A DASHBOARD
THAT WILL BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
OF US. TO TRACK THIS REAL TIME
SO THAT WE CAN REACT AS QUICKLY
AS WE NEED TO. WE KNOW HOW
CRITICAL IT IS TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A COMPLETE COUNT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
IN THOSE HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES AGAIN THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND ACROSS THE
STATE AND SO WE WILL BE
MAINTAINING A VERY CLOSE WATCH
ON THIS THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR
AGENCY AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH. STRAIGHT AND
THIS IS THE OFFICE- TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ALL STAY INFORMED
AND WE STAY ON TOP OF THIS SO
WE CAN ALL. ON HAVE A REALLY
GREAT RESULTS. THANK YOU I.
APPRECIATE THAT NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES ARE WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND WE WILL START OF
COURSE HERE IN THIS ROOM BUT AS
I DO THAT I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND GIVE THE NUMBER AGAIN FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO CALL AND
REMOTELY THAT NUMBER OF FOR
WITNESSES THAT WILL BE JOINING
US VIA TELECONFERENCE IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS CODE
IS EIGHT FIVE SEVEN NINE. SEVEN
FIVE ZERO. AND THAT IS ON OUR
WEBSITE AND WITH THAT AND IT'S
ON THE SCREEN IN FRONT OF YOU.
ARE WILL BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE- INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF
THE SECRETARY'S NOMINATION.
OKAY ARE SEEING NINE I'LL WE
WILL FOLLOW PROCESSING GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE JUST TO MAKE
SURE. WE'RE NOT LEAVING ANYONE
OUT IN SUPPORT. SEEING NINE I'M
GONNA AGAIN TURN IT OVER TO
MISTER MODERATOR WHO WILL
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS- WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
SECRETARY RICHARDSON'S
CONFIRMATION MISTER MODERATOR.
IF WE CAN JOHN ON THE AUDIO
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT YOU MAY DO
SO AT THIS TIME BY PRESSING ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT IS
JUST YOUR UP PLEASE ALLOW SOME
MOMENT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FOURTEEN LINE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY SPEAK. WHY
WOULD THAT BE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG THE COURT
AT THE QUICKEN TO TRACK I WOULD
WORK WITH HER IN THE PAST AND
DEFINITELY HAVE TO CLOSE YOUR
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY OF WORKING WITH.
I'M A LITTLE BACK WHEN YOU'RE
CLICK HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- MISTER MODERATOR
DOUBLE CHECKING ANY OTHER
WITNESSES NEXT WITNESS. NO BUT
I WILL REMIND YOU THAT IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OUT AND SUPPORT
FROM THE AUDIO PHONE LINES YOU
MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER ONE IT'S FROM LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN LINE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS REGINA BROWN LOOKS
IN ON AND I AM TODAY
REPRESENTING THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN EMPOWERMENT A LINE. OF
THE DEBATE AT THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHAMBERS THE END OF
WAIKIKI FAITH BASED LEADERS.
AND OUR BLACK MEDIA- I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO AND IF
YOU WANT TO PURCHASE AND FOR
MANY YEARS AND HER WORK AT
COVER CALIFORNIA. AND AS YOU
KNOW THERE WERE CHALLENGES AS
WE KNOW WITH ALL SYSTEM BUT I
THINK HE WAS THE RIGHT ONE THEN
AND I BELIEVE SHE IS THE RIGHT
PLAN NOW- TO LEADER COMPLETE.
GOV OP- GREW. A NEW
TRANSPORTATION. NEW
TRANSFORMATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS EQUITY AND PARITY
FOR EVERYONE. AND WE JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LET
IT OUR SUPPORT OUT WE SEE THAT
ALL OF THE MEMBERS. ALREADY YOU
SEE THAT. HER CHARACTER IS ONE
THAT YOU DID BE. AND BEING AND
THAT EIGHT THEN WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH HER. MAKE THAT A
MORE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THANK
YOU. YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. NO ONE CURRENTLY IN
THE QUEUE. OKAY MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE WILL TALK WITH YOU IN A
MINUTE MAYBE LET'S COME BACK
INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AND SEE IF THERE ARE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NINE
WE WILL FOR PROCESS SAY GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO ONE THERE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE MISTER MODERATOR I WILL
COME BACK TO YOU AND SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE ON THE LINE IT
WANTS TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ON THE
AUDIO FOR ONE IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
DO SO BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE TODAY
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS AND I WILL LOOK TO MY
RIGHT BEFORE MY TWO COLLEAGUES
VIE FOR WHO GETS TO MAKE THE
MOTION AND I WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT IT IS SENATOR ROTH WHO
WILL. MAKE THE MOTION THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM I MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I. MADAM SECRETARY LET ME
DO IT SECRETARY ANY CONCLUDING
REMARKS YOU WANT TO MAKE. NO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME AT
THE COMMITTEE AND ALL THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING ITH YOU-
ALL ESPECIALLY- ON CENSUS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL. THE EIGHT. FIVE
EIGHT I MONNING ALL RIGHT
LEARNING I'D ROTH IRA. ROTH AYE
WILK RIGHT WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE. IT IS UNANIMOUS
CONGRADULATIONS. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATE PARTICIPATED
IT'S SO HARD TO SPEAK SOMETIMES
THROUGH THIS OFF- PARTICIPATED
IN OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE YOU CAN VISIT
OUR WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS
AND AGAIN YOUR COMMENTSAND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR TESTIMONY IS INCLUDED IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION LET ME THANK
STAFF WHO HAVE CONTINUALLY
GOTTEN BETTER AND BETTER AT
HELPING US BE ABLE TO DO THIS
AND MEET OUR OBLIGATIONS
LEGISLATIVELY IN OF COURSE TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE YOUR COOPERATION ARE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES IS
NOW ADJOURNED FOR. IN.